when the Queen of Soul past Kelly
Clarkson said quote Aretha Franklin is
the reason why I sing from that part
deep inside of me that few could ever
reach and last night
Kelly reached down deep to kick off the
USO
honestly this is going to be so funny
people to me somehow this is actually my
first tennis match I've ever like gonna
see like in person so I'm and I'm
watching Serena Williams I'm opening for
Serena
so Kelly may have been a tennis newbie
before performing at opening night but
watching Serena when her first match may
have converted her
[Music]
Serena donned black and brown 2 to
tennis dress from Louie Vuitton designer
Virgil a blow and Nike but the new mama
had something else on her mind today was
a weird day for me I was coming out and
I left her I left my hotel and I was
like Mike I didn't get to say bye to
Olympia so that kind of broke my spirit
I was like okay Serena don't cry you're
gonna see her tomorrow don't cry the
celebs in attendance were talking about
Serena's catsuit controversy after she
wore the outfit at the French Open
officials banned it from future
competitions but the skin tight suit
served a purpose it prevented blood
clots
Serena's suffered near-fatal clots after
giving birth I think once you know the
real reason why she was wearing it but
listen I love her attitude you may skip
over superwoman suit but you cannot
strip her of her superpowers and that is
absolutely the truth it's ridiculous no
one's perfect and it always talking
about our bodies and what we can wear
what we can't wear I don't hear too much
about the guys do you short answer by
the way if Serena wins this tournament
she will tie the women's all-time record
of 24 Grand Slam singles titles
[Music]
[Applause]